fifth NHL season for Quinn Hughes
as Bard now racing to the Pu D ji
there as well JT Miller bouncing on it
finds bisser the shot and he [Music]
scores and just like that the Canucks are off
and running it's two to nothing for Vancouver
the season renewed wanting to get back to a
great start and this is how you do it you come
out excellent for check by the Canucks here DJI
this line combination's been together all training
camp for the Vancouver Canucks DJI to Miller
beautiful little backhand pass this is skill
right here little quiet spot besser left alone
and he did not take that much time to get that
shot away two nothing conu what a shot it's fair
to say they won their share in the first period
and such a focus on the fitness aspect as well
which is something you you know firsthand about
Rick talking you and him have spend some time in
the gym together here's heroni coming in with a
wrist rebound Jack Campell made the initial
save with the connect [Applause] score and
it finds its way in Campbell trying to deny it a
second time it's a patient play of besser great
backhand feed the first opportunity on the
rebound gets jammed towards the net and then
besser just Waits first chance right there it's
Miller that has the first whack at it and watch
this out of the air besser just kind of TAPS it
through besser accepts the pass gets it over to
Hughes back to besser besser now gives it over
to Pon moving into kzo Pon has it again from the
corner Elias Pon and that pu trickles into the
net Brock bisser hatrick for zip for the [Music]
kxs when you're having a night you're having
a night no question about it this Line's been
really good and now for B's third goal the
natural hat trick for him three goals in a
row to give his team a 4 nothing lead and
we're going to see steuart Skinner come in
here where Miller would be who is going to
be the recipient of this Puck goes off the
toe I believe a besser and boom Finds Its way
in the net he still had to wewi Al Campbell
to get that pad down and try and stop it but so
hard to change your mind once your mid movement
across from post to post and it finds its way
through no question he's stopping there's Hughes
with a shot towards the net and Brock besser
has four tonight in the kak season [Music]
opener and after everything Brock besser has been
through in the past two years you couldn't have
asked for a better start here tonight in the
right spot at the right time you want to score
goals in this league it's never a bad idea to
get to the net you can see broberg has him and
then he just kind of flares around around him as
two guys taking one in front it's JT Miller double
team but that leaves Brock Bessler open goes off
the shin pad of Evan buard another lucky bounce
if you want to call it or a creative Bounce by
being in the right spot putting a puck to the net
and for Brock besser he's been in the right spot
tonight bangs at home for his fourth of the game